I think there's a possibility that the
economic downturn will lead us to think
again about our values in general
including our views about poverty on the
one hand and also of course our views
about consumption so I hope that will
happen I couldn't really say that I'm
highly confident that it will happen
because you know once assumed once once
the downturn is over and the economy
picks up again you can't be sure that a
bit of that old acquisitiveness and
competitiveness won't kick in
so the most important is that you make a
commitment to share some of your income
with the world's poorest people and I
suggest a scale as your income increases
as to how much you might share that
scale is in the book it's also on my
website the life you can save calm and
you can go to the life you can save calm
and see the scale and then pledge to do
that pledge to give the percentage
that's appropriate to your income and so
that's two steps of the seven-point plan
making the pledge and then and doing it
publicly because I think it's important
that people should talk about this
should do it publicly so that the idea
spreads and more people can see that
other people are giving because then you
get this virtuous spiral going on you
get more people giving because they can
see that others are doing it and so it's
easier for them to give psychologically
and so then you get still more giving
and then it gets still easier for others
to give so those are a couple of the the
steps and I also suggest that people
become politically active citizens and
contact their elected representatives
about such things as trade policies that
are harmful to the poor and developing
nations so there's there's I think a
whole lot of things that active citizens
should be doing to try to get some sense
of urgency about the fact that there are
10 million children dying every year
from poverty related causes and that we
could prevent that